this market in yemen's capital sana is
stocked with food most people can't
afford
rising food prices have become more
evident during the month of ramadan
when traditionally muslims break their
fast after sunset with large meals
ramadan this year is different from
other years prices are crazy in the past
people were able to at least buy the
basics but this year they're completely
helpless
access to fuel is limited in yemen a
two-month ceasefire between houthi
rebels and the saudi coalition was to
bring relief by easing a blockade and by
allowing fuel shipments to rebel-held
areas
but the impact has yet to be felt
the price of food is ridiculous people
are crushed some of them can't afford to
buy the basics it's a catastrophe
seven years of war have devastated yemen
pushing millions of people into hunger
and not being able to purchase basic
food staples has hit communities
particularly hard during ramadan
we've started ramadan with great concern
this year because of all the high prices
limited fuel has made everything more
expensive
the ceasefire went into effect on
saturday
families here recognize it will take
more than a few days to ease the years
of damage caused by war
katya lopez al jazeera